there's a medical office in las vegas
where you can get a detailed look
inside your body before signs or
symptoms of something as serious
as a heart attack or other ailments show
up dr john pierce with preventative
diagnostic center is here
to tell us more about that dr pierce
it's good to see you hey kendall it's
great to see you how are you
great this is pretty unique technology
for the val
for the valley tell us what it looks
like and what it looks for
it is really cool technology we have the
only
ct scan in the valley it's actually one
of the only ones on the west coast
there's another one up in palo alto
but what's unique about it is this scan
really gives real high quality imaging
by using the lowest effective dose of
radiation for the individual patient
so it actually measures the patient's
density before giving any
radiation so we can get these super
quality images
and get down to the details of about the
size of a grain of rice which is about a
millimeter to three millimeters
so we can see any abnormalities in the
areas that we're scanning
which typically uh is basically from
just below the chin
right on down through the admin abdomen
and groin
so we're seeing the thyroid we're seeing
the heart we're seeing the lungs
we're seeing liver kidneys spleen
pancreas although the digestive tract
right down to the gonads in men and
women so if there's any abnormalities
like a tumorous growth or something
we're going to see it and be able to get
people to
take proactive measures long before
there's any lab
abnormalities or even before they even
feel
different so a lot of people go to the
doctor when they don't feel well
in some cases that could be a little too
late
yeah certainly uh peace of mind for
people who get this
we mentioned in the beginning heart
disease it's an ailment that uh has been
called the
silent killer because sometimes there
are absolutely no symptoms before
someone
suffers a major heart attack this scan
possibly can help ward that off
right we're able to see coronary artery
disease uh
and we've we've been able to evaluate
patients
to where i called the patient and said
listen you've got a significant amount
of coronary artery disease
you need to get in and see somebody
they've gone to the cardiologist
and i've actually gotten reports back
from cardiologists saying hey you
basically saved this person's life they
had no symptoms
we found an 80 90 blockage that they
went in there and stented
so it really avoided a potentially fatal
heart attack or a fatal event
which would have been devastating for
the patient and their family
that's absolutely amazing is there an
ideal patient an age range
of someone who should get this done
basically between 40 and 80
you know there's always exceptions to
the rule but that's kind of the ideal
age and
you think about it you know in our 20s
and 30s we do all kinds of crazy things
and we don't really feel that we're
suffering any ill effects from it
but by the time 40 or 50 comes out we
start to feel some of those effects
well when i turn 40 i'll tell you about
it thanks dr pierce
we'll see you call preventative
diagnostic center at 702-534-7900 or you
can find them online
pdcenterlv.com there's a special offer
right now
heart scan with calcium score for just
125 bucks really good deal considering
it's normally 599 dollars